parks oh he wanted that technical
demarcus cousins with some words you
know with the suns not only
had they not made the playoffs in the
past 10 years zero playoff appearances
just one winning season
and they had some brutal seasons winning
19 games
21 games 23 games last year they turned
it around a bit as coffee misses
the technical free throw by going 8-0 in
the bubble
you could see things were starting to
change young talent
and then they added chris paul and jay
crowder and this has been a dream
season for the phoenix suns and it's not
over yet
[Applause]
[Music]
both coaches emptying the benches so
much emotion
for chris paul he's going to be in the
hall of fame someday
and now he's going to be able to play
for the nba championship
an impressive performance here in the
clincher
[Music]
chris ball back-to-back rounds with
brilliant performances again he had 37
in the clincher against denver in the
second round
41. here in the clincher in the
conference finals
[Applause]
robert sarver the owner and a
disappointing ending
to what was such an impressive playoff
run
for paul george and the clippers and
again the
struggling last couple of games against
an excellent clipper defense they
explode for 130 points
56 percent shooting from the field
oturo shot won't go follow misses but a
whistle and a foul
[Applause]
and they will have home court advantage
in the finals regardless if it's
milwaukee
or atlanta that series tied to two games
a piece in the east
again ironic that chris paul coming up
next sportscenter with scott van pelt
live post-game reaction plus how giannis
and trey young's injuries change the
eastern conference finals
and the best thing that's fair of
heartbreaking playoff losses
but a time to celebrate as he will go to
his first
nba finals willie green
former nba player and assistant coach
violation and now the clippers will just
dribble it out
another big road win for this team
they've had
so many of them game four against the
lakers games three and four against
denver
and now games four and six here against
the clippers
in the conference finals as the
second stick down the western conference
finals are done with phoenix suns
for the first time in 28 years of going
back to the nba finals
[Applause]
those two coaches mark you right they
did
magnificent work two great young
basketball minds
such respect and admiration for each
other
we appreciate your participation
and a rough ending for paul george and
the clippers
some spectacular performances tonight
was not one of them
and you love to see this respect at the
end of a very hardcore
playoff series and you look at ty lue a
former player you look at johnson
phillips a former player
they understand paul's
march to try to get to the nba finals
and be a champion
you know how hard that is and they they
they're acknowledging
his greatness and his pursuit
they lose only four games there's mark
bryant
the assistant who's done wonders with
deandre ayton only lose
four games in the first three rounds 12
and four
in these playoffs six and two on the
road and they are your
2021 western conference champions
and i just want to say this there are
people that say well chris paul's not a
winner
because he didn't win a championship
chris paul getting a phoenix suns team
to the nba finals
to me is more impressive than some teams
that's won a championship
you know how incredible a feat that that
is a team that has
lost recently know nothing about winning
well every place he's gone mark